breedings to podcast Ville Monday March
25th you bad [ __ ] the church is
brought to you by let me ask you a
question don't you want to get your cool
ideas into a new website showcase your
work maybe publish or blog some content
sell products and services and walk time
let me tell you something you can do it
all with squarespace.com beautiful
templates created by world-class design
is powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online with the
ability to customize the look and feel
settings products and much more with
just a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so do me a favor go that
squarespace.com for listen a free trial
when you're ready and launch use offer
code Church CH you are CH to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain again free that squarespace.com
at the code church but it's not free you
get a free trial and then you save 10%
when you're ready to rock n roller right
that's what Squarespace is all about the
church is always brought to you by
listen my bookie the first week on the
NC double-a tournament is the greatest
betting event of the year and you sit
there again broke thinking should I
whether you fill in our brackets picking
out national champions predicting first
round upset or all of the above my
bookie is the perfect home for you do me
a favor deposit with my bookie today not
tomorrow not Wednesday I don't give you
gotta borrow from [ __ ] grandma 100 I
love promo Kurt if you put in a pro a
yardstick you get 50% right one hundred
and fifty [ __ ] dollars to get your
mother-fucking party started go to my
bookie today with promo code Church for
a 50% signup bonus that's promo code
church with my bookie you play you win
you get [ __ ] paid and that's
all that matters in my line - you're not
speaking about getting paid listen it's
time you think about your future a lot
of you guys are young
Robin Hood is the way to go they're an
investment that that lets you buy sell
stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission-free commission-free
while other brokers charge up to $10 per
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
any Commission fees so you could trade
stocks and keep all the profits that's
what I'm talking about
plus there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
investing at any level with Robin Hood
you can learn how to invest in a market
as you build your portfolio and that's
the most important thing
so what Robin Hood's gonna do is gonna
take the church family and give you a
free stock like Apple for the sprint to
help you build your portfolio okay it
starts by you going to church dot Robin
Hood calm again church dot Robin Hood
calm uncle Joey's always looking after
you right Lee
check this [ __ ] meal Felipe
spies in the [ __ ] house one of
the best of the business what's up fool
you know me dawg
look at that you're looking at [ __ ]
old you get my new you when you were a
baby with a short term haircut the
picture now and [ __ ] look at you now you
look you right now it's like you are
fasciitis he was still worrying your
heels no my plantar fasciitis the other
heels yeah who the [ __ ] you think he the
only way you don't think I know my
[ __ ] for our burgers dies oh yeah you
know I snuck into a couple [ __ ]
medical classes I'm having sex
doggystyle with a [ __ ] stepping on a
tennis ball so both your feet hurt
no just one that was more on the left
okay so they give you a koala sole shot
yet they give me [ __ ] bro it's a doctor
are you gotta go do that by Google the
heal time is up and then when it starts
to get really bad Felipe when you get up
to pee at night that's when you feel it
as you get up the first time it's a pain
that's unbearable bearable bro
unbearable and well this is the sack
that develops it's abhar sir so what you
have to do is either your business easy
you go to your doctor he gives you a
referral to a foot doctor you go they
feel the Bur so they do some x-rays and
they give you two options they give you
the options of a cortisone shot and then
you
the [ __ ] the orthotics it let me tell
you what I do put the orthotics and
stick to them religiously
if you switch shoes put them on a void
[ __ ] dancing disco shoes avoid
[ __ ] Merengues avoid you'd say yeah
nice you cannot wear those shoes you
gotta wear like you know you get into an
age where somebody goofed on it some
young time because uh I love to see
these men with their New Balances let me
pay some [ __ ] on Thursday mornings and
Sundays when I'm walking through those
airports I got New Balances on with the
orthotics in it cuz you walk two miles
at the [ __ ] Airport
I walked eight points on [ __ ]
Thursday and I think I walked seven on
Weight Watchers I swear to god that's
how much you walk at these [ __ ]
airports so for all that and then I had
to stand on my feet on the weekends yeah
so I had it when I was young
cuz I used to run with Converse sneakers
and I got bad and the first time they
shot me and then they put on a sonic
said then over the years I truly ilex
away I gained a hundred and fifty you
talking about plantar fasciitis yes yes
so he must have had a really really bad
I had it in both feet but in the less
long time in the left
closet the heat nothing here but the the
middle ear for right away broke that the
way you walk
Jeff laughs II know but I got the rule
of feet you do I did I couldn't I won
New Balance my entire life I have flat I
can't do [ __ ] you nationalists and it's
really weird I was thinking like going
to the Good Feet store yeah they
advertise a lot but the problem with
that is it's like people who buy nose
clips sleep apnea you still gotta go get
diagnosed you can buy the all the
[ __ ] pieces online for your 3695
and you're gonna put them on for two or
three weeks and then you're gonna take
it off and your sleep apnea is gonna get
worse and that puts a big strain on your
heart so you got sleep apnea
just calling the [ __ ] doctor the
mouthpiece that you buy online for nine
million that's gonna work
that's a bandaid on a [ __ ] and you
gonna have to pay for it later on with
that plant this [ __ ] if you can't walk
really bad you can't work yeah we do
stand-up comedy so I I'm telling you
this because mine just started acting
about four weeks ago ever since and bro
at the gym when they're right my thumb
there's no running I'll get on the air
machine bicycle if they're doing
something I just do hip escapes and you
Jitsu I can't run without those art
dioxide yeah get it no more jumping rope
no nothing like that like I don't go for
none of that [ __ ] because it just makes
it worse and that that hour on stage I
think it started for me at 45 or 46
those two hours on stage affect you you
don't feel it till later on especially
when bad shoes if you weren't bad shoes
because when you don't calm me you're
throwing your energy at them but it
starts by grabbing the energy from the
floor it's a really weird thing to say
to people listening you're thinking what
the [ __ ] are we talking about even pills
and know you'll see is you get it more
and more into comedy and you're
headlining Cedars and vinyasa that you
you actually find yourself ripping the
[ __ ] floor you know so at the end of
the night when you sit down I'm gonna
get back up to take pictures you're like
wow wow my legs are [ __ ] soy yeah
because you just will pull an energy
from your legs the whole [ __ ] time
you know it's all pretty interesting so
was that I got a little like like a
tennis ball sized plastic ball with a
bunch of spikes and I don't rub my feet
on there like forever yeah that's good
you you get you you ask them you put on
them or just the ball and then where
Birkenstocks my child he'll good that's
not because it hits my palm of my foot
yeah but the foot adjust you can't have
the foot to adjust you have to have that
thing in the [ __ ] so you have wide
feet then I got everything I got five
feet I gotta [ __ ] yeah I got a I got
a fun a fungi toenail I even took a
picture the song guy told you know take
care of that what the fungi told me oh I
dippin it everything ammonia [ __ ]
Dracula
I'm talking about going to doctors my
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up bro like my [ __ ] was
like like damn I even seen a broken
lollipop yeah someone L look like Jesus
a lemon I'm gonna show you what the pink
I don't know if I want to see I got my
two brothers of my own ale I I will take
my socks off of the shavings
I will remember being there girls how's
this my socks are at the pool with my
socks on that's disgusting
rotten looks like an eight ball of coke
we got much I shaved off my feet does
your foot that's my foot I put it down I
take the [ __ ] does your nail a black
I take the dog now the [ __ ] table you
fall that far you scrapes it off I got
like a [ __ ] foot stool and I've cut
the nail I cut all around and they have
an ingrown L - no no no I used to years
ago when I first moved to Colorado in 83
I wanted to buy her the place that I
sued you sue somebody I sued this place
near eh Parker corn you it was the front
of their business I slipped him from the
front of their business than I sued him
I think I'm gonna buy sneakers because
they had a deed is cheaper than anybody
else for like cool I was cheap when I
cross the street but I went in there was
new dollars
yeah like instead of 34 was 32 in those
days isn't that the same thing you
didn't like getting back in your
hometown when you were jumping in front
of cars at the front of the Cuban
restaurant you know what it wasn't me
yeah you know my cousin Joey what hey
guy right there and it was a favorite
Cuban restaurant like big ballers you
know and a lot a big bar little Cuban
Bollywood pepper other cars and he said
you join his frame okay to jump in front
of the cars I had a friend of mine
Armando I figured what his last name was
my dog God rest his soul I just heard
about four years ago that he became a
professional I get hit by cars change
this and they would shake you down for
like ten thousand cash there's no
business there's no like there's no
career [ __ ] ending in there you're
gonna get hit by a time a car wrong
maybe got a couple pills in you and you
hit the [ __ ] bumper and there you go
your head get squished
he got hit by a hearse no no I did the
slipper for one time and that was it it
was just it was so it was so [ __ ] up
like you know it it's so [ __ ] up how
corruption works like you're looking at
this thing that happened we USC and
these skids and William H Macy and all
this [ __ ] and you look at how many
people were involved [ __ ] coaches
again racketeering you know what that
means Felipe then as soon as you make
bail and let's have but I put the ballot
for you and we've turned around and you
go let's go talk let me buy you lunch as
soon as you give me your credit card to
use it it don't work no then when you go
to your bank to try to get cash counts
of seized that's the feds
that's racketeering your life has
changed them you're doing time you're
doing something those people have a
million dollar bail they're doing
something but I don't know how I got on
this with you corruption corruption
that's how corruption works you gotta
think about I'm not saying nothing bad
about because they weren't you have the
number one show on television but a
felon in 1987
you got the cosby show yeah you know I'm
the affidavits I read where he tricked
them in the trailer with NBC you mean to
tell me not one security guard seen
[ __ ] walk out of there with their
hair all [ __ ] up with their eyes
crossed you know there has to be so many
people for [ __ ] like that that happen it
happened yeah he had heard the show yeah
if he would take women to the trail and
then all of a sudden they get a headache
if he put like some [ __ ] voodoo spray
in the air there's got to be some
chemical that gives you a headache and
then they give him pills make them drink
it way now who goes who does that who
does that if your wife comes to my house
and she goes our kind of headache I give
it two aspirins and put her on her way
who's gonna tell you later
unless Albus
being in the [ __ ] headache I know
right probably done under blankets how
severe can the headache be that you have
to lay down I'll be able a trailer yeah
so on top of that there had to be a
security going outside the trailer G
right really caught outside the building
there's just so many people and that's
what you know it's gotta be some type of
conspiracy all that we just all of us
watch never-never-land did you watch it
I have a escaping Emily escape and never
Neverland when you watch it yeah it's
about Michael Jackson raping kids but if
you have to look at it from a different
perspective you have to look at it from
the perspective of yeah even though he
tried and looking look at his [ __ ]
look inside that he bet me over he lick
my anus oh they said that yeah Julie
McCullough you said good you know what
it takes a kid he was a 10 year old
[ __ ] kid you know another kid is gone
no it's a [ __ ] nightmare but how
about the parents donating them though
if you let your daughter go over there
what your daughter was there hanging out
with [ __ ] you now no Jonah - Jonah
brother listen you you have people and
your friendship
you always keep guys on your kids you
know you always keep guys like you I got
that crazy uncle I got I got a listen I
got a daughter now in about two years
you gonna start on this she wants to go
to sleepovers I'm not gonna be able to
sleep at night I'd be parked outside the
[ __ ] house or I gotta have my wife
tell her the bad news that she's not
allowed to go but it's a different time
yeah listen man I came from a society
somebody touches your daughter you got
to put a bullet and that's just the way
it is that's just the way it is you got
to shoot him in the leg you got to send
the [ __ ] message you don't wait for
the cops to prosecute them then they
bring them back and they move into
another [ __ ] town there's a gym
teacher and that [ __ ] place doesn't
do the background check is that with you
and that's what happens though reminds
me how do you think these people keep
doing what they're doing
people stay quiet then it's a short
father embarrassed I just heard a great
story I just wasn't Buffalo the guy at
the casino was Thomas
they hire the girl and he goes you know
it takes 30 days to get hired here
because of the extensive background
check he goes the first day they said
they hide this girl they said for the
Canada to make a pickup she got stopped
at the ball that she had a felony
they said till you have to turn around
and don't even ever try to come back
here again that will [ __ ] throw you in
jail she goes you know the background
check Huggle was the background check
they didn't find the family whether it
was from 12 years ago only went back
then it's like when you go to the doctor
and give him a [ __ ] physical an
awesome one day you're like I got cancer
well I gave blood tests oh but we didn't
check for that then what the [ __ ] you
take them what does go have to check for
what my lips sinks whatever the [ __ ] it
is red but you know you got a because of
money things they don't go for out of
the distance I haven't been touched by a
cop in 15 years so now I think if you
draw me up all that [ __ ] doesn't really
come up unless they look extensively and
that's when the real Jose Diaz ray joy
will the real Jose Diaz stand up I mean
it's getting with all these uber drivers
getting accused of stuff that had an
uber driver one on them on a murderous a
murder thing a couple years ago and
picked up riders in between it was in
Michigan I think he would kill some
people go pick someone I would do a
couple rides and Goku like you can't
trust anybody [ __ ] nine and half
drivers committed suicide in New York in
the last year because of financial
struggles because of what uber has done
to the cab guy and there's two sides to
the story
yet again guys sharing one car there's
two sides to the story the problem with
the [ __ ] the cab drivers is that you
know when you get the cab right off the
bat you flip the thing it's like six
dollars am to get into a cab and then
it's another when you get into Ober uber
saves you a little bit of [ __ ] money
and they're everywhere and it was
everywhere I'm not mad Roberto I'm not
mad at you know what I used uber and
lyft
both them me tremendous short distances
long distances on the road they save you
[ __ ]
you know and sometimes it's cheap and
sometimes it's [ __ ] expensive but I
know if I take a cab from my ass LAX its
buck - on it oh yeah take an uberx
elderly husband with the exit fees is 67
yeah 70 the paid for in the morning 60 I
got a [ __ ] car uber home your day for
$39 on Sunday because I got 50% off for
some they told you little [ __ ] gifts
and bonuses so I ain't mad at you but
sometimes I worry about who the driver
is if he just came from raping his
mother he just came from a bar in the 22
kamikaze we'll start talking too much
but I used to be an actor so far I've
had I've had mini Oklahoma drivers I had
an uber driver dog that I felt bad for
him but I also respected him with all my
heart he was a guy that worked as bla
bla bla and made dr. time 20 years and
he got old and they laid him off so I go
what's your schedule he was like come
out here and waters in the car he had
two plugs for you to charge your phone
in he had mentioned the car he asked you
what music he wanted for him the uber
experience was a game like 18 stars
right because it's it's it's it's a nice
thing you know in the old days if you
needed 200 bucks a week you so quaaludes
now you could pick up six people and
over and make two bills yeah no it's not
bad yeah it's all about who cuz I've had
I had one where some guy was no joke
watching TV while he was driving me home
I had a woman now I had a man he picked
me up and then I forgot my sunglasses in
his car so I forgot my I didn't think
about it and then I was talking to my
driver in the morning you know um I got
picked up a similar car like this and I
left my sunglasses inside and she goes
are these your sunglasses she oh yeah my
yeah my husband picked you up
hurt him and I we share the car he
drives for eight I Drive for eight hours
in the morning
he drives with eight hours at night
she's crazy it's crazy what the [ __ ]
ever [ __ ] sunglasses Becky
it's crazy with the uber phenomenal yeah
yeah can't [ __ ] believe it
I got picked up by David Faustino bro
but buddy
no you did not just kidding now a lot of
people started doing it I guess
Dunkleman started doing it to get
publicity yeah gotcha Rizal doesn't who
Martin Rizzo does he I mean for comics
and kids I tell you what man if I'm a
comedian and I'm starving right now you
got no choice God knows you guys think
you go to your car you can check on one
of your parents and go listen man I know
I've been busting your balls for years
neither 8th give me a [ __ ] uh let me
get a two thousand dollar loan to put
down on a nice car and I'm [ __ ] whoo
before 11 whatever it is you know what's
good about Ober you sitting there
watching TV nothing's going on you go
over for two [ __ ] hour but yeah you
know you're bored young you're back by
your house you want to leave me maybe
you want to go to the gym you jump in
there you can have a great [ __ ] life
on uber and lyft if you do them both you
all I know people who are so on it so
every services are good I loved it I
loved the [ __ ] whole concept man live
driver had the funniest lifts
thoris man if you ask him what the
craziest should have in your car and I
spoke to this guy and he said he picked
up Bob a little he picked up a little
person and a little person I was drugged
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] well he picked up
rat will it was get Barris and then now
he's a bright boy yes that makes our
breath I don't like you say [ __ ] we
don't pity he said
the [ __ ] was it able to breakfast the
old man said nah I'm he brings my wife
come on I'll take you to [ __ ]
breakfast he said the biggest stood up
they started struggling here for the
back seat bro
you know like Chucky pretty much do what
happened man I saw a police officer that
pulled up right next to him they
arrested that
if I'm a little a family overall I say
should I open the sunroof and shut up on
like a [ __ ] candidate if I'm a
[ __ ] uber lyft driving the more I got
two cameras in my car [ __ ] yeah but
let's say you can't do that though yes
you can yes you can just gotta have a
recorder bro you just gotta let them
know yeah I got a camera just with my
safety reasons if that's a problem
we get you another car understand you
cancelling I'm okay if you bet if you're
a normal individual well you got the
[ __ ] yeah I'm just sitting back here
picking my nose smoking the vapor pen
anyway yeah doesn't really matter but I
would put two cameras and for safety I
had a little bit driver pick me up one
night in lingerie a check that was
hotter than that ha and I could not
figure it out for the [ __ ] life of me
we had lingerie when she came out down
with the luggage I was like blown the
[ __ ] away she was Armenian very hot with
lingerie oh you mean like legit one
right yeah I didn't say two words about
I may believe like it didn't she's a
hustler I think she was trying to hustle
but it didn't even matter to me I had a
plane to catch I wouldn't know what to
do with her anywhere I'm too [ __ ] off
Wow
Jeremy I had a woman pick me up with a
her dog and the dog was sitting in the
first thing I've had that they're not
allowed to I know she's a do you mind I
don't think they too lazy I kept with
dogs or other people yeah that I see you
know I mean I I don't give bad rate
because it's their job I try not to give
bad but there was like someone who like
they brought it his wife in the car that
was creepy there was a wife yeah copilot
bro that's crazy you know last night I
was watching rocky rock he's been a
while I love rocks and they had the
rocky and I started bite here last night
I thought about how you like sort of one
of the Rockies of comedy Philippe
Philippe we did a lot of holes back in
the day bro a lot of them and they were
all fun like I well I see myself on
stage now and I'm doing certain things
in different moves it all started from
those little holes you know I was
telling me that yesterday you know we I
don't help people for stage time but I
tell them
the more spots you do the quickly you
get to the core
yeah it could yeah and you do people
right brilliant jokes for the first five
or six years in life they write
brilliant jokes they stick to the
pattern they're good jokes but
something's missing something and they
get like your own cans you get like the
Montreal yeah you get a couple things
you get happy goes away and you're
sitting in this limbo you're sitting in
this comedy confuse limbo you're a
feature act but you can't headline cuz
you got a little cry the handle credits
and then toughen up a facade and all of
a sudden one night you take this [ __ ]
[ __ ] cake there's some [ __ ] down and
you're up on stage and you're telling
your well-crafted manicured jokes and
somebody goes boo you suck and right
away something you get this reaction and
now you start just talking and you just
start talking with this cadence with
this confidence and within 28 seconds
you got it now it's building to a minute
and you've never done this materials no
never it's all new it's just you talking
about your mother okay some you think I
got [ __ ] problems you got a [ __ ]
movie [ __ ] left your mother booed you at
the school play let me things I'm I know
how do I know cuz I she booted me too
you know you're just going to this
[ __ ] tank and all sudden you get on
stage and it's like 200 pounds have been
done from your [ __ ] life and now you
don't even know how to explain what
happened you go home and you're like
what do I write in a notebook that was
who I am yeah man all of a sudden after
that for another year and a half it
[ __ ] it's you every once in a while
comes back and forth you feel yourself
there but you don't know how to keep
yourself thing you don't know man you
don't know how to keep yourself there
you don't know you tell this to young
you know like when you told about the
story about your gay brother yeah you
would never consider telling that story
the first five years hell a lot because
you couldn't [ __ ] him back it up you
can't back it up if somebody said [ __ ]
you and your gay brother
you gotta jump off this day yeah punch
him in the mouth after 5:00 to see I
wanted to take you to reveal that you
had a gay brother yeah yeah yeah yeah
who the [ __ ] wants to hear that you met
a gay brother maybe I wouldn't talk to
you little more if you said right or
wrong yeah
because the real you is who's
controlling your material not the person
you got in return I don't like abortion
joke but to stop that feeling I have an
abortion joke in Seattle my fifty I did
an abortion joke from my three weeks
then it got lost by itself you know why
because I don't like abortion how am I
talking about it it's a woman sure
whatever the [ __ ] yes I don't even like
saying the word during the show it puts
a stalemate to the show but I did it
just to get the feeling out of me too
man I never did one - recently I got 20
years don't like abortion jokes I don't
like Hitler jokes onstage it puts people
on even unless it's something you know
good something good it took me 20 years
to say Hitler onstage
whoa it's over 20 years with a abortion
I think him 20 years Hitler like when
Jews Hitler I think they're picking off
the lote-tree
go up higher Steve don't say Hitler
you're Jewish and I feel bad for that I
just wrote one high no he hates it
no Joe hate it I'm happy that you're
even thinking that where I'm at you know
I always tell him that I was in shock
when I moved down here to see all these
Jewish people here BMW's I remember like
it's against your core you're driving
the [ __ ] car of people who took your
people yes and made ashtrays and this
and [ __ ] wool coverings are
thoroughly [ __ ] and put them in [ __ ] and
smoke dens and you know I don't
understand that you could sit in those
people's car but I guess that your
whatever how ways your history I don't
[ __ ] know some people still like my
mom won't do it she won't watch it Mel
Gibson movie there's juicer techno yeah
but it's weird because in Israel they
have Mercedes Benz as all the taxicabs
so it's it's hard it's hard but you
don't talk about printing your motors
stuff
she knows that ten years ago if [ __ ]
what's-his-name not gonna
doors and this I got get the lingerie
and we're going to town to talk about
Jews she was cool with him until
passionately Christ and really yeah yeah
that's what he said the racial slurs no
no in there it was that he was saying
that Jews killed Jesus that was the
movie that was the truth
no it's not yes the Romans killed Jesus
Pontius Pilate we sold them down the
river but once yes history Jesus and I
thought he was prosecuted for blasphemy
by the Jewish people and then they
wanted run him up to Pontius Pilate
Pilate Pilate know what to do because he
didn't really break a Roman law he broke
her Jewish law and it was like a it was
like this celebration and evil well
we're gonna bring a bunch of pilot
we're gonna bring up Baracus and then
we're gonna bring up on Jesus Christ
well and let the people choose who you
want for racket Barabbas or Jesus Christ
and Barabbas was set free and you know
he he killed a Roman and Jesus Christ
was sent to the crucifixion under Roman
law it's a beautiful thing Philippe I
didn't know you do that what'd you learn
that a rehab bro other oh they love
living in recovery homes and now we used
to read the Bible every morning like
have our morning praise and then we'll
separate after lunch after breakfast and
look like a AAA or any meeting how old
were you when you were real
who's 22 and how long was the rehab
process I stood there for six months I
got out then as soon as I got out I got
into a fight with my dad at home almost
caught off the wagon so I said [ __ ] this
I went back to rehab before I fell off
again for another six months so it's
other for a year volunteering no [ __ ]
I would like another counselor but I
would like a runner I was driving a van
full of arm full of men full of drug
addicts and I take them to the welfare
office to fill out their welfare and I
was taken to the hospital clinics
another charge of the van something I'll
be in charge of the whole cab like 50
men
so you wouldn't and is that part of what
the homeboy is cuz I've hardly talked
about that and I know he's a pretty
great boy up here introduced me to a
pastor named Jesse Higuera pastor hewan
that's his name and he owned he owned
but he ran living in recovery homes was
a man named Bill and together uh you
know even though that their Christian
father for the great boy or knows their
man damn it he's I know Philippe as far
as that he little man
so they took me in right away so what's
a believer can you explain the father
Greg Boyle because he has a pretty big
[ __ ] mouth for the great for you and
like he's a a Jesuit priest from Boyle
Heights and he started a little church
called Laurie mission little tiny Church
only like a hundred people fit in there
and he started I'm a thing called job
for the future because nobody nobody
wanted to hire people who live the
housing projects I give you they like if
you try to get a job outside like out of
many warehouses around the neighborhood
they look at your address and then hire
you
so far the great boy went to um these
companies and said um if you ha it's for
example if you hire joy Diaz if you hire
least cyan't if you hire Felipe Esparza
you hire arm Tom Segura whatever um I'll
pay them out of my money but let them
work there so they're actually working
for free but for the great Boyle was
paying their salaries out of his money
and if you like him in six-month hire
them so after six months they'll hire
only Joe Diaz and we sucked so Jodi
advised to get a job there permanently
there no move us to another job they
were pretty much father great boy obey
them to hire us so after a while he made
a lot of money and finally boil opened
up by my bakery and that way he hired
other like though the black sheep of the
neighborhood a bunch of people and then
he opened up on a silkscreen company and
he hired more thugs and then he opened
up
Metiria he hired a bunch of women and
that's how I started now they have a
homeboy bakery and the airport but what
happened when I want Last Comic Standing
before I want they were going through a
hard time they needed money so when they
asked me I Last Comic Standing
what are you do with the money if you
win so I'm gonna give some of it to a
homeboy industry and people saw it they
looked it up because I know people get
of money and I give him money
so now they're doing great yeah it's
pretty cool it's uh like one of the
things I paid them back you know right I
mean how hard is it like is it if you
had like the same high school education
or whatever somebody like it is being
like a former gang member like what
tattoo like does that stuff really hold
you back as much as they I guess is it
almost impossible to find a job or what
is it like well so some of these guys
that night come on a prison they've been
never like put 20 years or 15 I know one
kid and one black kid like another kind
right let's get a name of cartoon this
other guy got it laughs his name but
everyone was a [ __ ] and one was enough
from another gang and um a guy broke
down so those guys weren't up there to
see what's up but an older guy went up
there to rob them so something happened
that guy they robbed got shot and those
two guys were like 17 18 17 years old
they did a 20 man they came out with a
37 years old so you know who's gonna
hire them well what kind of job skills
you have if they were game gangbanging
in prison - so how far the great given
gets a mom a chance to work a time
homeboy industry and a bakery or yeah a
lot of my friends that I grew up with
and lit up getting jobs in the movie
industry
okay like hey that was the first job
that he had for us like I had a friend
named Timothy record he worked for Wendy
Lieberman and he was out he was that he
worked for a ROM he worked for first up
so he ended up working for first cub he
was one of the actors and um
in [ __ ] and when we were doing the
protest for the black kids not going to
school with one of the black kids so he
was a guy that they helped while he
ended up getting killed later on in real
life but nobody at least they helped
them you know it's you can't help
everybody it's really hard to understand
until you've been locked up but you've
made a mistake or you go to a rehab and
you come out and you try to be honest
with people but you try to be honest
with people yeah to a point you're like
you're like I'll eat my name is Joey
Diaz I'm here to apply for the job I
want to be a Baker's assistant fill out
the application and you have those
questions on there well you convicted of
felony have you ever been coming on you
have a decision to make you know after I
did my thing
I never marked those boxes well I didn't
lie and I didn't say the truth you know
I'm sorry I just left them open I had my
personal reasons I didn't want that
label you know but I have been in places
where the guy hires you and then the
word gets out you were in prison and now
people start breaking your balls it's a
really weird dynamic unless you've seen
it like I saw it in restaurants in New
York when I wanted to share in it the
manager down there was a racist white
[ __ ] from like [ __ ] I don't know I'm
a dick man had that transfer them yeah
he would always ride these three black
guys that were Busboys like if you don't
do the job right you can end up back in
the [ __ ] prison
don't push me to make the call and at
that time I hadn't been in prison but it
didn't I knew in my mind that someday I
was going to prison and I remember how
bad I felt for them that would always
tell him won't even mother thought they
should just knock him up let's knock him
the [ __ ] out and it was weird because I
had a job for a while at the galaxy
towers and they haven't give me a job
because somebody made a call but the
dude who was my boss from the minute I
walked in was like he didn't like me and
every week he was write me up for
something but there was nothing he could
do because the guy who
got me the job there hey there was
nothing he could do and it aggravated
him so he would pick on me like little
by little so it's really weird I know
what it's like to get a job for people
to treat you differently because you've
gone down a different path you know
whether you have [ __ ] like that too
on your neck we got out of rehab so the
father Boyle does something like that
you don't imagine how much progress an
individual makes just by making bagels
every day if I give you a direction all
right at first the first week you look
at his [ __ ] I got into prison to make
bagels how the [ __ ] am I gonna hang out
with my homeboys you know saying if I'm
making bagels but then something happens
you look at it from a different
perspective you don't want to make just
bagels you want to make the best bagels
because that's all you got is pride and
that pride it's like when you go to
prison they have these prisons know that
let you have dogs and cats and they
still have studies that those prisoners
who make contact with dogs and cats
before they get released into general
population the recidivism rate is down
because now they have something to care
about you have to give the felon the ex
drug addict the ex person who tried to
kill themselves yeah all those people
you have to give them a special
treatment not hands on you got to remind
the [ __ ] everyone so long hey
dog will you a [ __ ] I tried to
hang your child for the light bulb fell
off the roof go pick up the [ __ ]
garbage you know I'm saying I mean you
crank different jokes but that's one
thing that I respected what I read unto
them yeah so weird they have bred a
different form with markets yes
and I picked n chips and chips and [ __ ]
and I picked up the pamphlets I always
buy the bread I always buy something
even if I give it to the neighbor you
know saying like though I don't see him
up here at the farmers market but I'd
always see him with the Hollywood
farmers market with the dude who was the
dude that came in fifth in uh in
NBC's America's top comic whatever that
[ __ ] show you what's our attendance
Comic Standing he was a creepy dude
there was an ex-boxer day jay jay great
guy Rogen loves him I love him he knows
everything about boxing he used to have
Krrish a London Jay London yeah they
love to thank you I'm sad thank you
Saturday's Jay London would take in
Sunday's if you go to the Hollywood flea
market yeah the Hollywood Food Day on
Sundays you see Jay London taking
signatures there he's got like 20 feet
from a lot of our boxing yeah no no no
he knows everything about box bro he
taught me them he talked to me that
movie was you know there's two moves you
know there's one you get real close and
you get tired of boxing you rest her
hand on his shoulder he was another one
he got even the nose turned you headbutt
him
yeah he's crazy but one thing's got
awesome guy but no every time because of
you and I read the pamphlet one day I'm
gonna be you mention them you know
whether he's a pre whatever the [ __ ] he
is he did something yeah he did
I would love to be a part of a halfway
house like some type of because I knew
when I went to a halfway house it was a
40% 40% they were really trying but they
left too much of an area of a gap for
you to get involved in bad things so
there's more activities you have to give
them there's more things you have to
talk about there's different things you
have to try used to hate those [ __ ]
Manglish me too man
especially that the one one that's all
talking with one can do want no I don't
do those things I'll Swami the same Yuja
Ouija the Pacoima any kind of like
meeting no no it's none of that one man
when I was in Boulder I was for one
candle and we hold are a bunch of bad
dogs
right when I was in Boulder I was made
to go to a meetings as part of rehab I
don't hear any I would do whatever
because whatever was easy it's not
called I said honey end of the week it's
all the same [ __ ] [ __ ] different words
so I would go to hey Amy I went one
night to a midnight candle one oh my god
I lasted ten minutes I even put a dollar
in the basket usually wait till you put
a dollar in the basket and go to the
back and get the [ __ ] out of a you get
your little signature cuz you gotta go
to a piece of paper me I gotta go sing
that so dude but I would do come like 20
just put my five said this is on there
for me I was up those guys a flat broke
I don't give a [ __ ] though saying guys
for the small fifty they'll sign your
way their lives you're in the halfway
out when you want actually you gotta
come up with the small fifty I usually
go to the dog Narcotics Anonymous
meeting and white Memorial Hospital
every Friday from 7 o'clock to 9 p.m.
and I say you know I'm not gonna come
here has to mean [ __ ] gangsters here
but I committed myself to glass head or
somebody was in charge of the coffee and
they don't wanna do it anymore so I said
I'll bring the car for every week so
they gave me the coffeepot so every
every Friday I would show up early and
make the pot of coffee and then they'll
give me the money to go buy more coffee
and I was a coffee guy I never shared
[ __ ] I never say anything I just stood
in the back next to the some blonde
white chola and she was a charge of
doughnuts one meeting I was there I saw
a guy talking and at the end of the
meeting I shook his hand he goes do you
remember me Batman
and it was Batman nobody calls me that
anymore
You Know Who I am no I don't because I
loaned you my car for $60 and you
[ __ ] wrecked it not and you even had
to be the keys and told me all my fault
want some coffee
how long will you go out with drugs with
altogether oh man I I fell down fast man
I thought smoking pot you mean at 20
years old 19 and then the next year I
was smoking crack and 50p cuz 20 is kind
of late
from I was drinking already - 18 years
old you know we actually got to like
Indiana's another birthday party dog
I let her like TiVo killings like goats
slaughter rings I have to go to parties
brought my mom and dad where it started
at 9:00 in the morning
and they were like cut up our alive a
pig bro a real pig a whole pig and have
a pit full of lard and I'll put all the
pork rinds of the pig inside so we're
eating pork rind carnitas tacos bro and
then then my 5 by 4 by noon the current
of the other part of the the other part
of the of the pig and they're making
them tacos I will carnitas let's each
other on carnitas about night time so
all that leftover fat they get that fat
and they make a pot of beans nice and
they make tamales with it and we're
there for the whole day brought in the
whole [ __ ] pig but at 15 you could
drink in front of your parents with no
battery there was a bunch of beer also
but I'm doing like about 10 kids and we
would just grab a beer and it's sneaking
away grab a beer
sneak it away the more you would drink
drinks and that people leave the parties
when you were kid I never did that [ __ ]
you know what it was a little food
access to alcohol if I had friends that
would need a bottle I just go to my
mother's bar take one and put it in my
jacket just give it to thing just run
away out [ __ ] ask an old beater I got
a bottle just and I make my mother
scratch and I don't had an extra bottle
of vodka around here somewhere
you know I had so much access to alcohol
that he'd use it and like it Philippe
yeah I didn't like and then we had a bar
downstairs in my house and not Bergen we
had known are you made a left out you
can even go up the stairs to the kitchen
or there was down the stairs there was a
boiler room but the people who had it
put paneling up like a tiki room and
they had a little slot for bottles and
uh there was a little makeshift bar with
four stools
I just never dug it but you have that
will the very night to that record
player they opened up with marital wood
and then lit up they had
they had a small record player though Oh
upstairs they had the record player
there's how old I am guys we had the
record player in the middle and then you
the 8-track in the corner but you
controlled everything from the other
corner and it was beautiful it was a
long piece enter it like a regular desk
light like a long draw and then you
slide the case the TV would be
underneath yeah no VCRs OBC our cable
came and then you had to put the cable
like on the floor because you had the
turntable here you had the 8-track of
the corner and you had all the controls
for the stereos and the speakers were in
the drawers underneath the [ __ ] thing
so the stereo was a big piece of how a
material can later on you had to lit all
the answer by the other part of the high
fire to make everything sound good your
gross money Felipe at all what you guys
grew up with money now we had no money
man but I don't like government help no
my dad worked my dad was a welder he
worked at Pyke welding company and my
mom said that arm he was one of them him
his company they welded parts of the
Panama Canal
like everybody in America had a part to
do it look at now so my dad he people he
welded pieces of it that they shipped to
Panama to make the canal I got that job
for many years and but that was a welder
for a long time but um he get into his
car accident later on when I was in high
school and he [ __ ] up his back but
there my mom picked up the pieces she
became a assistant nurse at elementary
school and eventually she was like uh
the school manager and at night she's
the one that blown you balls and bats
and basketballs how much how old were
they when they had you my mom was I
don't know man I was born in Mexico they
were like in their twenties I guess god
that's just scary to me what just have
it like either you have to take care of
these kids and your oh yeah I still
don't feel ready at all and my dad has
seven bras
sakes SAP yes together way your mom my
mom bro what number are you I was like
number one
I'll go lightly number two key my
brother angel my brother Fernando do you
remember coming over them hell yeah bro
I remember getting caught twice
I remember brother dressing up like a
little girl and but um yeah I remember
getting caught that's it and what they
do was here oh man they um they locked
us up at the San Clemente in jail and
then they released us back then it was
like we were Mexicans were like fish
like like bass it was catch a release so
they were catch of smut getting in did
you write down your name and then oh
toss you back into Tijuana Mexico and
they took a third time for you to get in
the third time yeah and all mine he's
got it no I was my brother I have um
four brothers that were born in America
okay so just the three of us my dad was
already here but that was already
working here
my-my dad's cuz my dad's name nieces and
nephews and his cousins they were all
working here they came here like in the
late early 70s so they were working at
this column of singers are a record
company and they press records and
vinyls you know they put vinyls inside
boxes and they ship them in that was
their job my dad was a welder so when we
first got here
once we snuck in I think God we took
they took us to like a place where they
keep everybody who was illegal who
hasn't paid her their smuggler I guess
we sat there for two days till somebody
paid I guess I guess I didn't know that
I forgot that we were there for three
days and somebody has to pay so we're in
carson city of Carson and when you
finally grow up alright I grew up in
Boyle Heights I went to elementary
school called Sheridan and we all lived
in one room might have my mom with one
room in the kitchen that's it so we
slept on the same bed
how're the meals I don't remember man we
allow bees and home a flour tortilla bro
Max's three hours a day done full they
can make it happen eggs you wake up in
the morning and make like I guess a
hundred flour tortillas and boil a pot
of beans and then by night time she'll
make sure I'm sure I saw a potatoes bro
and my dad will bring cheese from
somewhere and will make us ideas eat
sometimes we were eat on Fridays with
rice and beans and flour tortillas but
we're good man I I mean I never complain
you think back about those days at all
it isn't part of who you are today I
think so man it helped me like
appreciate meals you know not to waste
food or time my dad told me you know
like he would give me advice like my dad
would come home dirty as [ __ ] you know
like a coal miner black you know and has
filthy filthy heart from well you know
they he told me I'm I don't know I don't
care what you do in life you know what
love is you have a job where at the end
of the day you don't have to wash your
hands to eat and I'm pretty booked
pretty much took as his vice provost and
a comedian when did you become a Dodger
hot ball dog boy
Oh before the crack after it before the
crack before drugs you were in good
shape
hopefully but you couldn't do that job
today [ __ ] no you fall apart at the
seams that bursitis would come back huh
that plantar fasciitis [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll be
over there with a [ __ ] doctor bit
menacing gag massaging my foot I got a
job at Dodger Stadium man when I was
like in back in 90 I don't know 1990s
damn but I was working at before no I
said I just did it when I was in high
school I was a souvenir senator bro I
used to have a leg up like a little
basket where several of doctor helmets
seven dodger koala bears seven little
bats
six pence
five cheerleading things a partridge in
a pear tree
yeah and I'll be walking around in a
steel avoid so dears
get your Dodger souvenir how would you
get up there for height before I catch
the bus I was like 16 years old 17 I
will catch the bus and they'll pay me
[ __ ] cash at the another show at the
end of the game how much were you also
have five sold-out four hundred $60
worth of merch I came home with 80 bucks
if I thought if I saw 200 I came home
with 20 bucks I'll get 20% of everything
I sold dude how explain the people who
don't live in LA how hard it is during
like this summer
like what was a day game like in August
a [ __ ] bro
goddamn but see bad I love my virginity
wearing that [ __ ] Chloe Brooke I was
working there bro and man one night I
don't know you leave every [ __ ]
baseball season is hot all over the
queer world yeah I don't mark carrying
stuff around in there was Astrid Austin
Yankees how was that a [ __ ] Dodger
game what swear Rafi God bless his soul
he just made everybody he just won't
Comic Standing and he [ __ ] was
spending money as soon as it was coming
in he got us three tickets to go see
Roger Clemens against the Dodgers and we
all [ __ ] win and it was right as the
Sun was melting us we were right there
where the Sun just kills you we didn't
know and when you get there will exam
it's empty around me because people know
not to sit there like Dodger game yeah
it's empty
learning us their alternate dads in the
hallway you're not supposed to tickets
like an hour before like we could see
Clemens his hairs and his nose is [ __ ]
but nobody sits there because people do
sit there sit there with umbrellas and
suntan lotion up whoof three fat [ __ ]
yeah yeah Eaton had a bull that's know
we were going to the store next dukes it
was the black people used to run on son
saying they had big chocolate cakes that
were delicious mmm
we're at the [ __ ] dodgy mean cakes
getting stoned and also had the three
innings
we start we had puddles under arms my
[ __ ] scalp had a hot tub so sunburned
I'm like we gotta go now I get cheap
tickets I go over twice a year with the
kids and I get cheap tickets a bunch of
us the kids get together I'll tell you
what it's a great time while I get the
reserve barking I woke up those stairs
right there i hook a [ __ ] left I get
on the elevator up and I have a great
time I take her with kinda her
girlfriends the church the preschool
I'll tell you what it's a great time I
love baseball C's wait - I just don't go
as much as I [ __ ] could I gotta get
in New York New York for a month and I
made Aria promise why not you only live
once something that walks the [ __ ] you
things you know baseball it's like this
time of year Greg Garcia [ __ ] you hit me
up to pick a bracket the winner gets
$7,500 2500 cash and 5,000 what a
charity of your choice and I couldn't
figure out who I didn't know who to pick
I mean Duke is the obvious for North
Carolina but there's always that
come-from-behind team yeah [ __ ]
that squeak each game by one per vine
Irvine UCLA still I know they're done
they're done yeah and either next year
and eaters that was the only way they
were on that was the only kind of Rudys
hoggle that made it yeah how many teams
are we down to them I don't know 16 oh
it's a sweet sweet 16 baby that's why
yeah yeah it was pretty exciting I
watched a couple games
I saw [ __ ] Duke just kill somebody
I saw [ __ ] Duke just marry somebody
I think I saw Duke on their first game
when they bury somebody but I saw
somebody else bury Seton Hall that were
white kids and me and my wife looked at
the school where it was it was an all
Christian school for hallelujah
these [ __ ] were playing old
school white back you are you may be no
no no no no no this is straw Stroudsburg
your South Carolina like that's how
small
and it's now called Stroudsburg don't
quote me on that
whoever beat Cena on the first round
look who beat seasonal on the first one
how many tenant is they they were
disciplined let me tell you something
they will [ __ ] they played white
basketball to the tee the defense the
passing they had a white kid on there
that was and they probably lost by now
because there was just too small of the
school
so whoever beat seating on the first
round what kind of offer they're running
putty squad but there's no a lot passing
huh playing like a Midwest receives long
things down Seton Hall they had a kid
that was putting up jump shots without
even [ __ ] looking at the goddamn
thing my buddy I want to thank Gregor
and the over Fairleigh Dickinson
University he got to the first round
listen like I talked to Billy arenda
today and I told you brother's got
nothing nothing nothing to be ashamed of
just getting to the n-c-double-a is is
something Greg and I go back to the 8th
grade summer 78 going a five star
basketball [ __ ] camp so for him to
even make it to the [ __ ] who they
lose their Wofford College in
Spartanburg Spartanburg South Carolina
the Barton bird dog and who'd they lose
to the poor guy on senior see if they
lost already because they're great but
they gotta get beat up by a bigger more
physical team down the [ __ ] line but
this for me when I watch this yeah they
lost the University of Kansas I think
yeah that's it they played somebody like
that I know Kentucky yeah debt that's
[ __ ] /m for you that the cardinal logo
it's like I was saying to you before
when I watched the movie Rocky I think a
lot about you in the comedy world
you're like a true [ __ ] Rocky
attorney but like they were they had so
many other Spanish comics - yeah then I
thought they're sweeping and it's
something you were out there sleeping
sweeping you were out there doing what
you're supposed to be doing and that's
creeping while you're sleeping
it's going out doings to be sponsored
and you never complained we never talked
with in those days you and I never spoke
about that it would never have you
remember our original conversations it
was always about where we're gonna do a
spot that night where's the spot tonight
don't I got no money where's the spot
thought I walk let me make the call and
you will call some cough a lie he led by
Edwin someone here they you know it's
just I don't see that anymore I'm not in
that circle anymore
they're probably they don't want to call
me because you know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna call them for $40
yeah do liam's but who looks real I
don't know you know the kid finally lost
a room out there I don't have her no
more in Ontario yeah he lost him look
there's done no more no more Liam's that
was a long Jew that was that was a he
booked me one time payment hurting for
the books then I saw the flyer there was
next week Jimmy Walker what the [ __ ]
what about the club we would do up north
the crazy kids that had the coked up
girlfriend and they would do coke
Stockton right no no no there was a room
um used to do an hour up he used to call
Josh walk he was friends of Joshua he
paid John in $30 to him lying on a
Friday she was a cokehead he would bring
you up and heat strike doing coke by the
time you got off stage him and heroin
closed up to the gills they had a little
bar and he always paid a winner man I
can only give you 115 I'd only give you
one 11 I'm saying I got only give me one
hundred and eighteen dollars to that I
got coverages and you took the gig it
was an hour away you said the Comedy
Store at 11:30 but I never ID no or
something right up to koala Ventura
you and I discussed it because the girl
we did coke with the girl
owner talking about the hot white girl
it was a room over there up north and
the the kid it was went or what yeah all
right and
I'm comedy yes 8:05 hey you know that
guy was talking about I saw a
documentary he was uh he was he's not he
does pretty good I'm air guitar yeah
it'll five comedy here at these two what
our white Jay was a couple 805 common
yeah
the Russian kid who was scamming people
who finally I know that SEM was the
Santa Barbara victims and they had Brody
go up there that does Barbara rule bro I
didn't join MIDI mess yes those are the
room boos I don't know hotel room you're
gonna leave and drive back home at the
college up there yeah but you did once
he got fired you a dowel down the coach
house the Coach House was in Santa
Barbara on the Wednesday nights are
Italian Dante used to book it mean me
and um other commonly to always go there
I was do the coach-house there in the
Coach House and now someone capistrano
and the same guy he had a room at the
galaxy theater and I did it with Willie
Barcena
the galaxy theater was where I'm Santa
Ana California yes
yeah Thursday nights it would be 200 it
was a step not a steak house at dinner
theater yeah dinner dinner dinner
theater it's still there it's still
there but no matters count only every
once a while somebody pulls a commie
that'd be a nice place for you to get
going yeah bro that same guy was booking
up the coach on in Santa Barbara the
co-chairs and and I've someone
capistrano on an off night and the guy
don't take a beating the first night but
I mean you got eating dinner during the
show you know they finish dinner they
finish okay
this is sitting there in levels it's not
doesn't see a lot maybe 200 that's where
first times I became with Joe friends
with Joe Rogan yeah we would be friends
from the [ __ ] comedy store slide over
the name of the guy collide and there
was very light our friendship and then
when they were both stuck on traffic and
when I look over these park next to me
he looks at me where you going I go up
on to the galaxy I'm gonna find the mine
tonight tell him I said hello that guy
was outlining I was featured what day
that
they did not like a dirty crowd at all
the galaxy in fact maybe six or seven
years ago I opened for Rogan there
before the UFC we're gonna show that on
a Friday night before UFC that was the
addendum but Gordon and going oh my god
I was here before I forget the killer
used to book it for me it wasn't Clyde
he was a kid that's still around that
one night made a weird statement about
me in front of me and we had to shut him
down because he said that if he were now
Ricky rather Latino kind on this
particular tease though this guy was a
white dude and he said you'll Bob Raquel
no hold you love me I'm not going
because you won't be able to follow me I
know I could definitely for all my you
guys and I'm a bit chewy look at him
going you're out of line and walking
away and that Thursday to do with
nowhere to be found
he was talking to bud what do you do me
yeah I don't know it was like a month
it's a type of thing that you go let's
see if it's true I'll see you there
Thursday I'll [ __ ] do my dirty ascent
up for you to [ __ ] off well come on here
with the energy of ten [ __ ] prisoners
just let him yeah man and you're not
gonna be able to follow that so why
would you make a statement that he's
still around
I still see mr. know that in movies you
know who gives a [ __ ] did you get by a
train how about blithe and broadly you
know them broadly for patchy de Geer or
or that that Aris Papa chulo eres
Patrick I have no idea brought some
wears nothing elevations no he's gotta
be blind bro he was blind and what is
gonna make it he was born in ten years
ago hustling more than people eyes oh
yeah he has rooms
I never disrespect them for that he'd
get there hey Joey I got this baby
Pierre i'ma see you in oh yeah he always
had [ __ ] room dog if there was an
opportunity for a room I respected those
guys
hell yeah there was a time we got it
those guys at one time you like Jesus
Christ
what an awesome human wall-e was awesome
you gotta go back and go in a second
they're offering me money to apply my
trade
he always had weird games but they
weren't the garden they're not the
Comedy Store not the improv weird gig
was a gig what about the [ __ ] gig
that the guy was weird as [ __ ] and he
used to book Wednesdays at the Irish bar
in Huntington Beach or those beaches he
was from Boston he was really creepy
with a beard he booked that any booked
what supposed to mean what's above if
I'm going to Simi Valley what do I pass
I love that they did allege enforcement
no they did a lot of Calabasas [ __ ]
I'm bet the Cuban dude God rest his soul
he need to have the goggles
god I hate to wear those big eyes he's
just a little bubble lions no no that
was it what was his name
old guy he was gone blind he had thick
glasses he would hosted the Laugh
Factory and when they actually pulled up
and his face was in the poster Franky
kosnovski Oh Frank Asti Frankie Karl
Rask EO he moved to a New York yeah he
could call Rica yeah big big [ __ ]
Glasgow ride around you cannot he
offering blind bro he was blind him
Patrick this Caroline is a little bit
more blind abandoned then custody over
Patrick till this day gets the utmost
respect from me an appreciation because
I don't forget like watching it member
towards the end his wife started coming
in yes
your kids your kids and he was up there
with the [ __ ] stick calling doing
open mics and I would bump play Madden
I would bump into him places and he
would be really serious about his trade
like he was really [ __ ] serious he
wasn't
the world on fire Felipe but you look
back and you go Jesus Christ I'm getting
inspired by it
man armor he booked me one of those
shows and he liked being fats [ __ ]
dinners bro like I'll [ __ ] your fat
steak shrimp fries everything right
we're eating and this person like a
crosses across my mouth having a heart
attack and he's dying and then like
everyone stopping to eat and I looked
over at him hey Patrick are you gonna
stop eating I got tired over there brah
okay I can't see [ __ ] man I can't see
him but you feel like the Mexican rocky
of comedy hell yeah man like where you
came from and how slow the process was
very slow how slow was it until you got
the last copy it was like um when I got
to Last Comic Standing I've been doing
comedy what nine years ten ten and now
I'm like 22 that was 12 years ago has
come with me on that 2010 there were
nine years ago Jesus yeah but you
learned bro like I learned like oh there
I was headlining button they pushed me
out there but like you say like it's you
learn bro like I remember borrow me one
time and I'm looking at the audience in
Atlanta Georgia and it was like 38
people on a Thursday and then I got the
said I'm you know what um normally if I
was doing comedy for like two years I
would think that I was bombing tonight
then I sucked but now you guys sucked
you guys sucked
you got failed as an audience you guys
suck
I'm good you guys are not great because
you are not ready to even be you know
[ __ ] open mic room you this audience
is not even ready to be in a bring the
room like you're not allowed to get
invited to a ringer show then I got the
crowd back bro cuz I really thought that
they thought I didn't suck I did my job
these drugs work everywhere but here how
do you blame the crowd some time oh and
jokingly yes but we've done you like me
you blame yourself yeah bail [ __ ] yeah
I've made myself you want a crowd
when I'm killing up there and when I'm
killing but later on in a room and feel
like nah man you cheated
you went back to your old jokes or you
know you did something you did something
bad like how what do you think about
that going back to yo I feel like it's I
feel like I would for me is a cop-out
like and I know that people are not
gonna laugh as hard you know because
they already heard it but I know there's
some who haven't heard it but then I
feel like I don't even listen to the set
then I see these old jokes on you go see
Santana to it
yeah almost last time you want to see
Carlos live Carlos Santana yeah never
the first month the first [ __ ] 45
minutes - Carlos Santana he does two
things he talks you [ __ ] ear off and
he plays music you don't even want to
hear when you're dead skin understand me
then the last 30 minutes he does a
rendition of combo you come over and
that's when you look around and you see
people going crazy Nick they're coming
back with a [ __ ] it but in their balance
I'm thinking a say a day I'm [ __ ]
driving and I heard black dog by Led
Zeppelin the most played album in the
history of the [ __ ] yeah I'm sitting in
at one point I hit a light and I caught
myself being the take him back how come
when you go see a musician and you see
their setlist
they got 15 songs 12 of them but it
would be longer [ __ ] ones I know from
the previous albums if you want to play
your new [ __ ] save that for the farmers
market yeah man hell yeah you think that
works for comedians hell no because when
you're when you're doing comedy there's
a surprise element at the end yeah you
know he's just surprised you surprised
that Joey said [ __ ] teabag you know
but when you hear it like over and over
they're a little more surprised you're
just smiling no no that's why I give
myself so much time in between cities
yeah you never wanna I don't want them
to see me like people go to the same
cities the same time every year it burns
me up like yeah I got material sense to
the Netflix special thank God you know
where I got it because I'm not
it won't come to you my way you're not
sweating material and you don't give a
[ __ ] if I come to you and sample and
give you $10,000 to [ __ ] do a special
on August 15th you doesn't wanna [ __ ]
be riding like John Mulaney you have a
gun too yet yeah I need a team I might
do a CD this summer like an August just
to get this hour done and started
another one so I hear what's going on or
whatever but I gotta tell you in the
beginning of you will issue a special
I'm not your children specials not long
no I think that Dave I think it's time
for us to come up with something
different this comedians a movie to
refresh yeah a movie I think it's time
but not not like a scripted movie
something different something that mixes
the elements of animations your family
where you came from an excerpts of your
calmly I think because people are
listening to podcast and then knowing
who the [ __ ] you are yeah then now they
understand when they see you and Lisa by
the pool cooking a [ __ ] cake out of
carrot the [ __ ] you do you know yeah you
guys the trainer Joe's trying organic
apples
I get excited Joey like we're numb I
know you don't do Thursday through
Sunday you do Friday Saturday Sunday but
no I do I love Thursday pro Thursday
Thursday is my night Thursday's my
eternal night Thursday you might hear
jokes you're not gonna hear oh yeah
you're not gonna hear all we ever forget
up but I'm aware of my style up there I
love to always have Thursday's my facial
I don't mind like this we can add it's
already gotta be tight I had a Thursday
yeah Late Show this in Pittsburgh cuz
see cuz it was overwhelming but I
usually like Thursday fun you know I
hate when they come and they go how much
time are you doing on Thursday we don't
know
does it matter maybe 115 because I'm
gonna try everything that's in that
notebook and I'm gonna find out what you
feel that box you feel younge huh so now
the first show Friday
you've chopped it down huh 250 but now
the second show you rotated some ma'am
and now the set is tight that's cooking
baby feeding into them out ba-ba-ba-ba I
love that [ __ ] I love that whole you
could back it
governess that's why I loved it Felipe
yeah I love it now you know that the
Comedy Store more but who's me I know
you live far from there but Felipe view
in town for the week just call in for
Tuesday and Thursday and do all three
shows do the main room do the original
and to the belly room they'd love to
have you
who do I call all [ __ ] not the
[ __ ] thing called uh Duncan Trussell
no no no call me check that Emma yeah
something like that
how fun aim is in my phone you call on
you go
don't put your boat oh you do the
original and you do Sam tripolis bang
room the hammer spots
that means you can rotate your jokes and
for different situations take a bombing
yeah it'll probably bomb in the belly
room for the 10:00 show but you might be
you're tired by that time yeah that
bills comedy endurance you know you
don't know you can lift 350 pounds until
you try it you're gonna try to go [ __ ] I
can lift 280 but I gotta get up to 350
yeah it's the same concept
I loved when I was doing my [ __ ] with
you when you and I were running hard in
the early 2000s we were doing three
sponsor three spies I'm in what time I'm
at the 15 spots in our lane in one week
oh yeah yeah that's that was the you
know that DJ with a fucked-up hand he
got me a couple of DJ Reuben he got me a
couple of gigs I got a couple of gigs at
the Stephen State House there's always
the money and always always 75 bucks 75
bucks somebody oh and a bad piece of
meat oh my god look bad it's just a
little better than take them it's like
yeah it's like the guy hasn't died yet
and something fell then that one leg did
that maybe they had Camacho's for a
while on a Sunday oh my god come on
March was one of my favorites right I
love that put a [ __ ] Sunday broke
Camacho's I asked somebody somebody
picked me up their day from moving away
you probably goes Lakewood
I go is the hop still there I don't know
what you're talking about he was a young
kid yeah
then I explained them that tangy is it
on the hop
on a [ __ ] Wednesday night pace
yourself tacos outside no gloves no
gloves Lee they would give you a coupon
you can have a coupon for three drinks
or coupon for tacos we will get there
tremendous we'll get there early bro get
[ __ ] high outside the parking lot
come inside Eagles and watch Thursday
night nitro its pilot for Bombardier
time for Lee mmm something's hit them
you know it was comedy in a live band
stopped over you know it's hitting me
the good good to say yes see that's uh
no more smokey for Lee he got as my last
week he came back with 20 stories they
gave him a bottle of cough medicine with
cold the kunafa
you think he brings in it to share with
his friends no he's a half a fruitcake
you think he'd bring it and give us a
shot of cough medicine so we could be
ware of the bronchitis he's gonna give
it my brain doesn't go I'm not hoarding
it who thinks to bring in cough medicine
for summer you should have it on you
just for little sips would [ __ ] like
sambuca they say you can't try them on
it bucho and you believe that [ __ ] do
you believe everything Lee I try to my
god
I Drive around the neighbourhood but I'm
not gonna drive [ __ ] know you could
drive from the m1 [ __ ] thing a
[ __ ] cough medicine let's do you
really read the labels and so they told
him you know what this guy told me what
there's something wrong with strip club
I just called to see if they had a cover
charge she called this strip club this
is one idea what ladies and gentlemen on
a Saturday night and Buffalo
Wow wouldn't gonna jump out of he called
the strip club to see if they took a
[ __ ] if even if they did let you in
for free what do you think I'm let you
see those hookers for free no not take
it down can you imagine that people but
I got a deal with this come on Lise I
decided to make a ring it makes it
partly cloudy with chances of yeah but
in the future I didn't bring the Kaufman
because the label says not to drive that
label over there with the edibles says
not to do dick yeah I still gotta go to
up and down take my daughter I gotta go
pack I gotta go to New York
[ __ ] - do you know how many you know how
many four four clicks I operate it how
many after eating pills chewing oxy
cotton [ __ ] that's how you drive your
best nothing you go down you're more
sure of yourself when you're all you Bri
a tit man oh my god
don't shake everybody but I see bone on
it'll be any until midnight
probably so be until midnight we don't
make a bet what dates you got coming up
G money I'm gonna be an Arlington improv
this weekend Thursday through Sunday and
I'm gonna be in where can they go what's
the world of Filipa WorldCom's imagine
where all the [ __ ] dates and just tell
them whether you know
April 4th through the 6th Charlotte
North Carolina and I'm gonna be April 18
through 20th and Tacoma Washington with
Rachel Wolfie same for the reboot orient
Johnny rocket will be there for 4x and
put a picture of her up today she's a
beautiful young girl she's funny bronze
if you know I even know her her father
her mother is a judge who put AJ in
prison in jail she looks like her yeah
yeah I heard about that about she's I
gotta get around this show on he's
pretty cool Philippe you're one of my
all-time favorites he was so full beyond
the Comrie you're one of my brothers
don't forget to watch the dirt because
he says I'm gonna watch the dirt at the
end of it he looks at all four guys they
don't care motley crue ever strums alone
again I just want my brother's back hell
yeah I want my brothers back I'm happy
you come down here how's the podcast
door what's up fool so comedy is doing
great bros out you know if it was 100
degrees I was on the way you sweat it
you sweat shirt fits beautifully thank
you yeah I'm just I'm just waiting for
the right opportunity if you know that
we're friend us know so we didn't want
to feel I'm saying if we're gonna bust
that I'm gonna bust up on something big
bust it out write something
Felipe Esparza I love you to death me I
will be in pen only only available is
four four ten o'clock for Pittsburgh at
The Improv in Homestead
you know I love your [ __ ] I
can't wait to be there and we added a
second show at the Pabst Theater for
4:29 a briefer and 419 is sold out in
Minneapolis and that's it and that's
that real quick I just want to run you
down on something cuz you know me I love
our sponsors I sponsors are the best out
there we started off today with Robin
Hood it's an investment in it lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commission-free that's just
a starter while other brokerages charge
up to $10 for every trade Robin Hood
doesn't charge any Commission fees at
all so you can trade stocks and keep all
your profits again profits plus there's
no account minimum deposit needed to get
started - you can start investing at any
level
it's simple intuitive design of Robin
Hood makes investing for newcomers and
experts alike view easy to understand
charge market data and place a trade in
just four taps on your smart phone just
four taps and you're making money you
can also view stop collections stretch
as the one most hundred most popular
stocks and with Robin Hood you can learn
how to invest as them in the market as
you build your portfolio my wife loves
this you discover new stocks you track
your favorite companies and you get
custom notifications for price movements
so you never miss the right move moment
to invest that's important Robin Hood is
giving the church family listeners the
Church of what's happening now a free
stock like Apple for to sprint to help
build your portfolio and get you started
in this world where I think you should
start making some investments so sign up
today at church dot Robin Hood dot-com
oh the sweet sixteen you [ __ ]
it's time to make some [ __ ] Jesus
whether you're filling out a bracket
picking a national champion or
predicting the first runner-up cents all
the above my bookie is the [ __ ]
perfect home for March Madness fun if I
had a board I'd blow it right now anyway
we'll zeon williamson and his teammates
cement their legacy at Duke for the
idle or can Virginia get past its was
the sixteenth seed last year and can
Kentucky get back to the Final Four
who the [ __ ] knows who that my bookies
got the [ __ ] answers if you know the
answers or if you even don't my bookie
is the place to get it on the action
they got some for everybody even you
multiple bracket [ __ ] guy anyway
my bookie has been in business for years
their goal is to give you the best
customer service in the business and the
best part they pay when you win I'm
plucking 48 [ __ ] hours but with the
best then kick back enjoy the [ __ ]
mark man that's why you watch your picks
make cash that's it so what I'm gonna do
is I want you to put a little deposit
with my bookie today it's Monday I know
you got the money you were saving it to
go take the girlfriend somewhere [ __ ]
up you gotta start with my bookie promo
code Church for a 50% signup bonus that
means you invest a yard you get an extra
$50 that's promo code church with my
bookie you win you play but most
importantly you get your [ __ ] money
which is the best thing ever you
understand me now you ready to start a
new business you want to make it stand
out you're gonna get started with
Squarespace you thinking your dream it
you make it and with Squarespace destiny
is calling and it's telling you you need
a new website make it with request base
the future is coming make it brighter
with Squarespace you want to keep
dreaming or making a reality
with a website from Squarespace the
world is your oyster
you're like Joey why because you could
turn your cool idea into a new website
you could showcase your work and you can
blog and publish content right there
right there beautiful templates created
by world-class designers with a powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online with the ability
the customer has the look the feel the
settings the products and more with just
a few clicks nice and easy it's got a
built-in search engine optimization free
and secure hosting nothing to patch or
upgrade either act 24/7 award-winning
customer service where you
that listen cut the tactic BS head to
squarespace.com for a free trial telling
you free alright and when you're ready
at lunch bubble boom use cold word
church CH you are CH to save you 10% off
your first purchase or website or domain
it's that easy
sign up right now today for a free trial
and when you're ready Squarespace is
there to deliver the goods that
squarespace.com and the church okay I
want to thank Squarespace I want to
thank my bookie and I want to thank my
main people over at Robin Hood to put
this together I love you guys are on my
heart Felipe Esparza go to Felipe
Esparza flavor inspires the Reapers
WorldCom's last tour for all the dates
or your dates and listen support this
guy when he comes ooh brothers opal when
you're in the East Coast go see Philippe
Riley respect he keeps just tickets more
out of respect for you go see this guy
this is a talent that you cannot [ __ ]
miss you understand me don't make me
[ __ ] repeat myself to eat I want to
thank the Flying Jew aka the Christ
killer the original but most importantly
I want to thank you guys for giving me
the opportunity to come into your
[ __ ] living room yeah thank you very
much earplugs once or twice a week
alright I love you guys thank you very
much for listening or you could do is be
a little bit better today than we do
worry yesterday a little more suck you
think if you ate three Vikings yesterday
eat do today you're a lot better off
than with you happen yesterday
stay black I see you [ __ ]
Wednesday morning what a tremendous
podcast just like this one
ly check this [ __ ] meal